SCP-682 Vs SCP-294.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile Vs The Coffee
Machine.
Could this supernatural Keurig brew up a final
victory over this ornery reptile?
Researchers got the machine to dispense “SCP-682
Killer”, and poured it onto a tissue sample.
The sample crumbled into a fine powder when
it made contact with the
liquid, so they cumulatively
brewed up a liter of the stuff, and poured
it onto the actual SCP-682.
The affected areas decayed and crumbled just
like in the test, and when 682 was placed
back into its acid tank, the areas completely
dissolved.
The researchers felt incredibly hopeful, believing
that if a large enough quantity of SCP-682
Killer can be synthesized, it may actually
live up to its name.
We’ll let you know as soon as they try it
again with a venti order.